mir ist jetzt aus dem krankenhaus
zugeschaltet yaka visier von cinema for
peace guten tag herr visier
als allererstes natürlich die frage wie
geht es ihnen aktuell sie lägen aufgrund
ihrer coruna erkrankung momentan im
krankenhaus
ja hallo ich bin ja auf den pc stationen
der charité
ich wollte vor zwei wochen mit der
friedensmission von cinema for peace am
berg karabach reisen und beim check
mannes hat er festgestellt dass
iss-bewohner habe und was sie erschreckt
alle menschen nicht die zwei tage voll
getroffen habe habe ich angestellt das
heißt die fiktion ist einfach
unglaublich stark momentan und ich habe
das erst nicht so ernst genommen
dachte ich erhole mich ein paar tage die
sie dazu zusammenbruch kam und ich dann
auf die intensivstation kam mit der
aussicht ins künstliche koma gelegt zu
werden
aber wogegen wir natürlich hart gekämpft
haben was uns dann auch gelungen ist das
ein inkubator ging das ging aber eben
auch nur hat hier tolles pflegepersonal
dass ärzte und eine tolle versorgung die
man nicht gefährden sollte durch zu
viele infektionszahlen wie schnell hat
sich ihr zustand so dramatisch
verschlechtert sie hatten gerade selber
gesagt am anfang dachten sie müssen
nicht nur ein bisschen ausruhen wie
schnell ging es dann das jedoch ins
krankenhaus hin sogar auf die
intensivstation mussten
das ging von
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
am montagabend auf der intensivstation
und kämpfte wirklich 48 stunden um jetzt
künstliche koma zu fallen so wie wir
wissen werden ja nicht alle wieder wach
jetzt ist das genau das krankenhaus auch
in dem navi alexej nawalny behandelt
worden ist sie hatten dabei geholfen ihn
nach deutschland zu bringen nach dem
giftanschlag auf ihn
was ist das jetzt für ein gefühl für sie
haben auch gesagt sie hatten das anfang
nicht so ernst genommen jetzt auf einmal
zu sehen wie dramatisch die synchrone
erkrankungen verlaufen kann dass sie
jetzt selber auf den stationen liegen
müssen
es ist unglaublich ich habe die rallye
hergeschoben weil herr geführt
ich hätte mir niemals träumen city mich
auf einmal retten muss und dann auch
noch ausgerechnet die gleichen ärzte
also die intensivstation hier auf der
charité werden gelang es professor
eckhard das war mein ansprechpartner bei
einer wahl nicht über passiert und wir
haben uns natürlich die großen erstaunen
die augen geschaut als sonst auf die
intensivstation wieder getroffen haben
was ein bisschen irritierend ist jetzt
habe ich vielleicht genauso schwer
getroffen hat ich habe einige seltsame
beschwerden bekommen
seid ihr da waren die rettungsaktion wir
müssen herausfinden welche ursache das
hat aber vielleicht ist das der grund
warum ich petronas verstärke getroffen
hat wie lange genau sind sie jetzt auf
der intensivstation und vor allem was
ist die prognose wie lange werden sie
wohl noch da bleiben müssen
das ist jetzt eine woche liegt die
kritische tage waren vergangenen montag
bis donnerstag
seitdem ich es bewegte besserung also
ich muss keine sorgen mehr machen aber
das nicht langsam wieder zurück ins
leben finden dann ist das wie beute
machen töne zu singen wieder normal zu
atmen
ich bin hier 24 stunden am tag die
sauerstoff unterstützung
also wenn ich zehn minuten in dem bett
stehen kann den physiotherapeuten ist
das schon ein großer erfolg
also das hätte man sich niemals
vorstellen können
das was wie es einem geht und jeder sein
um halt das ist unglaublich
ihr blick jetzt auf die krone situation
in deutschland wird wahrscheinlich ein
ganz anderer sein durch die eigene
erkrankung wie denken sie jetzt über die
maßnahmen der regierung seitdem sie vor
allem selber krank sind was hat sich
dann ihren augen und in ihrer sichtweise
geändert dem früher hielt sich die
maßnahme für übertrieben
mit verweis dass eben den sie stets leer
waren
das hat sich massiv geändert
infektionszahlen sind explodiert das
personal fehlt mittlerweile das sind
alles alles helden sieht hier arbeiten
ärzte pfleger die kommen aus allen
bereichen
jeden tag werden neue stationen dazu
gebaut alle sind improvisieren hat sich
auf einem hohen medizinischen niveau
aber um das alles hinzubekommen das ist
jetzt wirklich dringende maßnahmen sie
lockt sonst müssen es durchgezogen
werden es muss endlich richtig
eingesetzt jeder bundesbürger muss seine
tracing etwa das war weist er ist gesund
die maßnahmen die wir bisher griffen
sind halbherzig und um wirklich
todesfälle zu vermeiden um die helden
unserer gesellschaft hier die pfleger
die ärzte dass kein neues personal zu
unterstützen müssen jetzt alle viel mehr
tun und es ist zu viel leiste faire
diskussion auf politischer ebene und was
euch auch wichtig ist neben dem was wir
schon wissen machten tragen isolation
betreiben sich fernhalten ist uns eben
auch richtige action einzuführen ist
ganz wichtig dass auch die impfung jetzt
so schnell wie möglich vorgezogen werden
ich denke wenn die menschen alle geimpft
werden und wenn die tracing apps richtig
eingesetzt werden dann wären wir ohne
besiegte
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren